what thoughts do you have on DIY release
strategies the I guess the criticism I
get a lot are the things I hear from
people all the time are I don't
understand that business he stuff and I
don't I don't get the distribution stuff
and you know it's always I'm gonna focus
on making my movie and somebody else
will deal with all that truth is today
it's never been easier to produce a
movie or any type of media content in
general the technology is fantastic the
costs have dropped tremendously and
anybody can do it
the problem is because anybody can do it
there's tons of it and so it's more
important I think now for filmmakers and
writers to be cognizant of what is
needed in the marketplace and how that
whole end process works and the great
thing is that there's never been a
better time in this industry for people
to do it all on their own
anybody can create a website anybody can
create a blog anybody can build a fan
base using social media platforms
anybody can you know spit out and leak
information about their title and build
up an audience and build up an interest
and have that magical moment when the
product is ready to be released already
have a great collection of people out
there willing to buy it so it's a I
guess my view on it is it's just there's
never been as much power in the hands of
individuals and individual content
creators as there has now and I think
that's only going to increase so I think
the ability to take a project an idea
from beginning to end
cheaply effectively with very strong
results has never been more in the power
of individual filmmakers so for those
people who want to do their you know
project that is outside of the
conventions of what I talk about in
writing for the Green Line they
certainly can and they you know should
pursue what they want but if you still
produce within the genre conventions I
write about you're gonna see a lot more
traction I think on the professional
side because that's gonna stand out a
bit that they were able to put a project
like that together make a bit of profit
on it for a very cheap budget that's
somebody who can prove to themselves we
can bring them in and
you know they can shoot films for us or
write films for us or whatever
what can filmmakers learn from the app
world metrics
I think the incredible amount of data
and metrics that go into engineering an
app and how targeted and focused it is
very very specific audience I I think
that's what filmmakers can take away
from the app world what that opens the
door to is you know the genre
conventions are right about writing for
the green light are good on a grand
scale but some people want to produce a
documentary that's very focused on a
touchy issue that's maybe only important
to a very small minority of people
that's fine they can exploit as much of
that small percentage of people as
possible if they focus it and target it
and reach out to those individuals and
communicate with them same thing with
like faith-based content you know
there's a there's a great audience out
there and the stuff that sometimes gets
produced on it on a grand scale isn't
hitting the nail on the head the way
that audience wants it and so they can
kind of do it themselves it's I think
what we can learn from the app world is
how much data we have and how many of
the answers we already all have in our
pockets or purses and just with the app
world beta testing something can a
filmmaker really do that with their
movie it's tough to beta test a movie
beta testing is I think much better at
platforms and an audience response and
because of that once you kind of make a
movie it's sort of one and done and it's
either going to resonate or it's not so
you can take as many steps as possible
to enhance the ability for an audience
to be receptive of it but it's a thing
where you kind of got to know the
audience in advance and that's why the
distribution assembly-line kind of works
the way it does where it's all reversed
engineering it starts with the audience
and builds back to what movie should be
produced versus producing the movie and
then just hoping for the best that it
gets to the right audience
you